[Musique]
oh
un doudou c'est plus qu'un copain de jeu
c'est un véritable compagnon de vie qui
soit peluche animal petits monstres
il sèche les larmes de petits et rassure
les enfants un ami n'oublions doux
ça évoque je pense pour n'importe quelle
personne son enfance évidemment après en
tant que parent bas
on a une deuxième vie avec nos propres
aux enfants sur le doubs moi j'ai pas eu
de doudou nounours j'avais juste un tee
shirt que je très fouillaient voilà est
ce pour ça que j'ai voulu mettre en
avant le textile parce que je pense
qu'un doudou c'est pas forcément une
peluche ça pète toutes sortes de petits
bouts de couverture de tee shirts une
exposition réalisée par une dizaine
d'artistes avec la participation des
habitants de lui en cours pour
accompagner le visiteur bagatelle est
colossal de doudou imaginé par les
enfants des écoles de nos villes un
anneau nos mascottes bagatelle est
colossal voilà qui ont été faits par
marie-claire duyse une bénévole car
produit vraiment à l'identique les
dessins des enfants
on avait plus de 500 dessins donc
c'était très très difficile de choisir
l'expérience visuelle tactile et
sensorielle pour jouer au mieux dans ce
monde de douceur les visiteurs sont
invités à déambuler sans chaussures un
retour en enfance à l'insouciance